Jake's cool because they're simple and
mysterious at same time this simple
Eston a points out like yeah
two-year-old someone who can like to
babble and look at things with pretty
colors right recognizes what shapes are
and their differences and they're like
the first kinds of things you start
playing with I bit lose all of you will
have play with like I am is a toy and it
looks like this and it's got um it's got
holes in it yeah it's like everyone
plays with money right and what happens
is taller okay and they're all these
pieces and you have to fit them into the
right holes and they only fit in certain
holes right and then once you're done
and you know this there's this cool you
know you put them all away too much
you've done they're actually these cool
handles that you can pull out like this
okay you open the thing up right and
then all the shapes pull that and then
you do it again it's so much fun but
very very small children is my point
very small children play with shapes
because they're simple right like square
triangle circle simple ideas right but
but not only are they simple and easy
for little people to little little
people to master sure enough they are
mysterious up shapes are puzzling for a
lot of reasons let me give you an
example why ah what are tree trunks why
tree trunks always so circular like if
you sliced over it's a rhetorical
question
if you sliced open a tree you'd see
something like this always like a big
tree right
why should trees all of them everywhere
for centuries in trees have such a
perfect shape to them why is that that's
a mystery let me give you another
mystery um bees beehives right you can
draw a arms you could draw a beehive for
me who you if you opened it up and had a
look you sliced it open right be nice
have this very unusual shape to them
right they're made of hundreds and
thousands of these shapes and I'm keep
going right then made of hexagons
perfect regular hexagons every single
cell why is that
why not squares or triangles or some
other kind of shape that's a mystery or
again similar the first one right why is
it that by and large all planets are
spherical why why not planets like you
know cubes it's quick like you you know
or like a like a a cylinder US will be
like that why are they like that why
shapes shapes are simple but they hold
within them some amazing mysteries right
now there are answers to all of these
mysteries and some of you might even
know some important thing for us today
is that all these answers are unlocked
by that part of mathematics that's cause
this is among other things it's the
study of shapes geometry is the study of
shapes understanding what they are all
the different clients what kinds of
interesting qualities they have how they
relate to each other
that's your material the study of shapes